yeah welcome to this video a bit of a
late start here but they have that
ten-second tolerance now because i had
done screwed up my recording window we
are playing step-by-step he's not going
d for surprising him he's done very well
with that against me in the past ok c 4
yeah i can go see 697 yeah let's go see
six I still have a bad score against the
sky nine and a half out of 22 John I
like my Center but it's nothing nothing
out of the ordinary here it's not the
most ambitious way to play white but
well nothing nothing bad okay so I
cannot take on d5 two times at the end
as night xe5 so I rather castle yeah
again is playing with that little idea
that little trick ok I'm going to
prevent anything to g5 and then play
Bishop you six
check I have the space advantage chip
and i think i'm slightly more
comfortable so i don't really get that
one a 6b five okay when he wants to
connect rooks but anyway won't won't
lead to much and then quick because some
guy is also a quick player at the answer
not going to spend an enormous amount of
time young yeah thought night before as
good here isn't that good let's see
taking a cho and turn 93
and maybe you can take it and trying to
defend that position it's not much fun
but maybe what he has to do
I really don't see an alternative now
now kids it's something it took some
time because it's it's really not what
you want to do yeah yeah I can take and
play h5 who Bishop age 6 I wonder if
that is the best way to play on if I got
something better why I think it's okay
Bishop one aged six will be very
difficult for him to meet with my play
on the C file
check I'm ready for Roxy to
I had to see how he's not losing any
pawn now don't really don't really see
how he prevented yes maybe he can try to
get some counter play here with them
with a form but I can't play I wonder
maybe just this preventing a form not
sure about it but didn't seem bad to me
so let's go here and tie him to that a
pawn you can try to okay it's not doing
that so we wants to bring the king over
I don't end in mind that really I want
to go to the six and get the King to
control important see file squares I
always have bishops see one by the way I
wonder and not now I mean just cover it
now but I could have done that earlier
okay anyway
it's a good position as it is but I
could have played better that's pretty
clear let's see I don't get bishops e1 n
I can Bishop b3 is now possible a for
Bishop b3 check I had still a very bad
position for what he can hardly move
even though i had had more forceful
continuations but checking at Bishop c1
this is pretty difficult to count them
so I can go Bishop see one now is there
something wrong with that may be a 4 but
happy should be true care would be one
hmm that's true yeah maybe play that
first it's really completely completely
sufficient um I look see one also was
good actually yeah that was set was a
very very decent alternative but i came
i just have Bishop b2 next and Bishop a
3 i'm just picking up those pawns at
least I don't see a defense at least
now after you take c5 I can really i can
just recap chirps OH
check
ponds are just dropping before then a5
a4 and so on white resides yeah that
opening result was that that whole whole
structure was kind of kind of awkward
for what it's difficult to save he
really got into some trouble now check
well yeah I'm slightly better due to the
space but it shouldn't be shouldn't be
that terrible but not sure we went here
which is probably not a great idea i
mean King age to Bishop h3 is one idea
or sometimes they try but but here that
just it's that's awkward yes to he has
to do something about this and yeah if
he takes the position becomes very one
sided with black having the bishops the
space everything after Queen d2 I don't
know the capture ng5 looks pretty good
the computer wants to play a 50 no now
it wants to take and go g5 that's also
very interesting yeah that's very good
actually it's a good move I didn't think
about that the idea is to play the G for
Bishop h6 it's also very very limiting
for whites position but I don't think
that this is bad no not the engine
evaluate scissor so almost just just as
good yeah it gets into the minus three
territory yeah I actually played at I
could have played it much easier just
look see one yeah totally did not think
about that move and it just went
straight away it wins all the pawns I
really played hard to complicate it but
okay it is so bad he cannot he cannot
repair his position
so the way I've chatted just just took
way longer but it was just as yeah and
soon prospectus for wide it's just not
good I get this is a very important idea
this long-range bishop that helps to
fight for the seat file that's something
maybe to take from that game an idea
that is often often underestimated that
the bishop can help from a farm to fight
for that open file and that ultimately
I'm get tipped the scales in my favor
yeah well thanks for watching